we should explain what we're doing right
okay okay so we're gonna play we're
gonna play chess without turns
the way this works
is that we can make as many moves as we
want
but
after moving a piece
we can only move that piece again
after we've moved to other pieces
tata is the referee
and the videographer
is the hangover for this
so hopefully this makes sense uh good
luck
all right
all right countdown
my god
sorry
wait so can you leave a king in check
like going away from the board and
putting a slide it's kind of weird yeah
when you capture you have to put it off
the board
before you leave it okay what about
leaving a king in check
so it's all about capturing the team oh
so the king's in check and i have
like
basically two
turns of you making moves before i have
to get out
and let's say you're on the way to take
my king if i'm quick enough to move my
king over
then i'm fine
interception right
three two one go
so
um
what is happening here
buddy
so what happened
i didn't have any pieces we have a pawn
oh but he blocked your phone
yeah i mean you run out of pieces it's
not stalemate what kind of rule is this
it appears like we have a player who's
cheating
victoria sorry crozen
i tried